Super Dragon Ball Heroes has spent a
long time hyping us up about their first
fully 3D episode and it looks like this
here's the thing Super Dragon Ball
Heroes is not even really an anime to
begin with it is a short promotional
show that exclusively exists to drive
people towards the game it operates on a
shoe string and a half and anything it
does manage to accomplish is a small
miracle but even having said that I was
not expecting a literal video game cut
scene for an episode These models are
all taken directly from existing video
game models and slapped together like a
kid mashing action figures to smiies and
we're still for some reason they took
Gohan's unaltered model from budai ten
kichi 3 yeah the PS2 game that came out
in 2007 that was the last dragon ball
game I played and I was 15 I'm 32 now I
wish I was making this up but I'm really
not so please Dragon Ball dier save me
from this eternal suffering